There's nothing more horrifying than a plane plummeting from the sky.
But for members of an exclusive club of 14 sole survivors of plane crashes,...
...the experience is a lifelong badge of terror.
At least one confirmed survivor.
Yeah, one known survivor.
This is Cecelia Cichan who in 1987 at just four years old,...
...became the little girl known as America's orphan.
The whole world is rooting for Cecelia.
Flight 255 had just taken off from Detroit Metro Airport when it crashed,...
...killing 154 on board, two on the ground.
But out of tragedy, one miracle.
Four-year-old Cecelia Cichan has now been told by relatives...
...that her mother, father and six-year-old brother died in that crash.